North Korea is obviously in the news
right now and here's a couple things I
think it is absolutely criminal the way
the media is trying to lay this at the
feet of Donald Trump as though he he has
had absolutely zero to do with creating
this crises up until this point now that
being said I think it's a bit like a
police officer who doesn't know how to
de-escalate a situation you don't want
to go out and drop the verbal nuclear
bomb right you want to keep it close to
the chest so so not necessarily being
handled really well but the media wants
to go beyond the bend and say this is
Donald Rumsfeld no actually there
there's a slew of decisions and policy
enactments that have led to this current
crises okay and you need to understand
in action in and of itself and often
appeasement as we'll go through this
timeline is a policy that's been the
policy of the United States several
administrations for decades now so let's
kind of bring you up to speed as to what
has led us to this current conflict
directly because you can go with North
Korea you can go all the way back to the
50s yeah so you have to pick a point so
basically from 1985 onward North Korea
was subjected to an anti-nuclear
proliferation treaty so what change
proactively that changed in 1994 under
Bill Clinton so what happened there Bill
Clinton in North Korea signed an
agreement were they pledged to freeze
and dismantle their old nuclear reactors
in exchange for aid to build two new
reactors and at the time Bill Clinton
this is a 1994 praise the deal saying
North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons now this matters because
back then he said South Korea and our
other allies will be better protected
why because North Korea said they will
dismantle their nuclear program so even
leftist before Barack Obama listened and
I thought they acknowledged that the
world was safer and our allies were
safer if they dismantled their nuclear
program what happened after this new
policy 94 North Korea began enriching
their nuclear material anyway
okay so next step on the timeline let's
fast-forward to 2003 North Korea
reactivated a five megawatt reactor
capable of producing plutonium so what
what happened here they declared later
that year so this happened we didn't do
a whole lot later that year they
declared that they had nuclear weapons
which we often ignored we didn't do a
whole lot but they declared that later
that year as a result of this it almost
is no respect for authority so we have
Bill Clinton the floodgates summit
action from from George W Bush who was
dealing with 9/11 at the time what did
this lead to well here's what's
important I say inaction is a policy so
is appeasement because then we have in
2005 2007 and in 2012 North Korea asked
for aid from the United States and they
promised to stop their nuclear programs
and close their facilities they asked
the United States for help and we
repeatedly actually gave them free crap
in good faith and what happened well it
got worse and you have some sanctions
from the UN but we gave them stuff that
was policy for years even up to 2012
[Music]
[Music]
cultural differences okay so all right
we're gonna sign a deal giving you
nuclear capabilities as long as you
promise in 1994 and in 2003 hey we have
the ability to create nuclear bombs
they're bragging about it we give them
free stuff in Oh 507 2012 and what does
this led to in 2006 2009 2013 2016 and
twice in 2016 North Korea conducted
multiple nuclear missile tests or
they've claimed to add technologies to
their arsenal so what did we do after
all of these launches twice in 2016 all
of this occurred before evil President
Donald Trump well we either imposed
sanctions after we gave them stuff or we
ignored their claims or we went to the
UN who also imposed sanctions which were
repeatedly ignored and so this is where
we are this is where President Trump has
to step in not a crisis he created but
one that he can only do his best even if
it's not the best to solve
[Music]
you have to give the president at least
it's a it's a change of course would I
talk about fire fire and what do you say
fire your fire injury like anyone else
before no but you know what it is a
little bit like Les Grossman in Tropic
Thunder at some point the Vietcong sign
it into the phone going oh we might have
pushed the rule but they never played
our hand here that's all I've been doing
against it's 1994 we give we give we
impose sanctions they don't respect them
they launch some more tests and now the
left and trying to latest at Donald
Trump's feet says hey it looks like they
have miniaturised nuclear missile
miniaturize nuclear bombs and they can
attach them to missiles so that's what
pushed President Trump to respond all
right if this is the same let's try
something else
it's like having a kid you keep giving
him timeout timeout timeout timeout
it doesn't work at some point maybe
maybe you try beating his ass I'm not
saying it's morally correct I'm not
saying it's the ideal first choice but
it is a choice on the table I do like
that it's not been removed from the
table I don't like that we've shown our
hand a little bit now here's something
else though with this conflict I see
this a lot you see it from the left what
gives us the right well we don't want to
be the police so we'll look at what
makes the United States so sure that
they're that they're better first of I
don't want us to be the police of a
world I'm generally a
non-interventionist we'll talk with
Stefan Molyneux about that okay we don't
need to be the world police but guess
what there are plenty of other countries
with nuclear capabilities we're not
concerned with France we're not putting
crazy sanctions on friends the reason we
are with North Korea's because this is
one of the most heinous evil regimes in
history Lucia's relatives no it's not
they've executed people with
anti-aircraft guns they feed people to
dogs alive if you look at their prison
camps we have an estimated 200,000 North
Koreans they're tortured and by the way
torture over there doesn't mean they put
a face cloth over you and ask where the
terrorist bombs are while they pour some
distilled water on you it means forced
abortion starvation beatings human
medical experiments and of course almost
impossibly hard labor that's how you
know that we're the good guys and
they're the bad guys
the good guys always have to step in and
stop every single bad guy but let's
start off let's let's at least try again
common ground if the left wants to find
common ground don't say well Donald
Trump is is horrible at handling this
policy okay and by the way what makes us
so much better than North Korea now you
lost me you had an argument
yeah his rhetoric really won't help it
seems like it could escalate the
situation and buy what makes us so
confident what what gives us the right
what makes us think that we have the
moral high ground well we don't punch
women in the stomach repeatedly when we
put them into a forced labor camp to
enforce an abortion Oh Donald Trump a
someone from Goldman Sachs in his
cabinet okay let's go with that clip
from the full show Daily Show at ladder
with credit calm / mug club or it's
available exclusively $69 a year that's
less than $6 a month less than two
expensive cups of coffee or you can feed
an African child but just buy coffee or
join the mug club Daily Show ladder with
credit.com / mug club see you there
don't feed children